المترجم: naeem mohammad
المدقّق: Mahmoud Kadry
تيد اكس بغداد
مصطفى عبد الواحد نوري
فكرتي هي الإستفادة من حرارة اليد وتحويلها إلى كهرباء DC مستمر 5 فولت
هذه الفكرة استخدمت فيها أبسط الأدوات ، طبعاً هذا الشكل النهائي للمشروع
هذا استخدمت فيه أدوات بسيطة جداً
مثلاً أول شي جهاز thermoelectric
هذا جهاز يقوم بتحويل الحرارة إلى فولتية وأمبيرية
قيمة هذه الفولتية والأمبيرية استخرجتها من خلال هذا المخطط البسيط
بما أنه عندنا حرارة اليد جداً قليلة ، فسوف يولد لنا فولتية قليلة جداً
التي هي 20 ميلي فولت ، هذه ال 20 ميلي فولت جمعت 4 قطع على التوالي على اليد
ولد عندي 80 ميلي فولت
هذه ال 80 ميلي فولت كان عندي مشكلة في تحويلها ل 5 فولت
واجهني أكبر مشكلة في هذه المسألة
ال 80 ميلي فولت جداً قليلة ، نحولها إلى 5 فولت مسألة كبيرة
من خلال هذه الدائرة استطعت تحويل 80 ميلي فولت إلى 5 فولت
هذه ال 5 فولت متذبذبة ، اضطررت لاستخدام متسعة (مواسع كهربائي) ذات قيمة عالية 4 فاراد
يتكون من طبقتين, وظيفة هذه المتسعة تصفية الذبذبات الموجودة في الدائرة
وبالتالي سيخزن طاقة ويفرغها خلال نصف ساعة تقريباً
قبل مخرج الدائرة (output) استخدمت منظم فولتية (voltage regulater)
وظيفة منظم الفولتية أنه يثبت الفولتية على المخرج بقيمة 5 فولت مهما كانت قيمة الفولتية الداخلة
استخدمت على المخرج قطعة (USB), هذه القطعة نستطيع إدخال شاحن الموبايل من خلالها
طبعاً هذه القطعة سوف تعطينا 5 فولت مع 500 ميلي أمبير
هذه كافية لشحن الموبايل من ال 0% ل 100% خلال ساعة ونصف إلى ساعتين
وشكراً
تصفيق